all right time for our draft today the
best quarterback receiver combination
trivia question goes to chris patrick
mahomes did not join the 500-yard
passing club this past weekend which
quarterback
did join that club this
season this season this season
man who am i missing this year that
joined it
this season hold on i'm looking at teams
here
barely joined the club this season man
i'm gonna go with did dak prescott get
500.
you're looking down at the screen i
swear i'm not look look i got it right
here i'm just looking at standings right
here see that wait a minute
they they were a little quick with the
horns
because he didn't say final answer he
just said did dak prescott get 500 and
they hit the horns control room
way to go nicole in the control room
that she's from jersey she knows you
know
she knows how to do this she knows
jersey week four
cleveland game a loss 500 yards
dag press got 502 so
10 active quarterbacks are in the 500
club
tom brady ben rothersberger drew brees
phillip rivers matt ryan matthew
stafford
derek carr jared goff and matt
schaab who almost made it twice he had
497
once to go with this 500 yard game you
get the first pick best quarterback
receiver connection currently in the nfl
chris well
i'm going with the most the i mean i
don't care what happened last weekend or
not this is the one i
i've always think that you know this is
i think this is the best receiver in
football you know
and i'm going with hill and mahomes
tyree kill patrick mahomes that's you
give me my first choice i'm taking those
two
you know just uh not that tyree kill
will fit with any quarterback but he
fits perfectly with this guy
i know that and you know with all that
he brings to the table
not just his ability to beat people deep
but you know the speed sweeps those
those stuff all those things he does
it's special
defenses have to reorga organize how
they want to play when you play him
uh and when they connect it's for
touchdowns
i like that that to me there's a big
difference between a guy who's
got a lot of yards and stuff and it's
three or four touchdowns between a guy
and then another guy who's got
you know a lot of yards maybe not as
much yards as the other but he's got
10 11 12 more touchdowns he's making a
lot more
big plays that are influencing his team
win and i i think tyrique does that in a
big way
so in other words you like guys who
didn't get tackled that's right
i like when they flip into the end zone
backwards
i i i would say uh that this may have
been my first pick
even if you had gotten the question
wrong yeah which one are you gonna go
here
right yeah russell wilson and dk metcalf
because there's no more
fun connection right now because the
possibility of that moon shot
by russell wilson that goes straight up
comes straight down
and there's dk metcalf making the big
catch and metcalf one of the most
exciting receivers
in the nfl right now him and wilson
together and they aspire to catch
marvin harrison and peyton manning for
the most all-time
quarterback receiver touchdowns they're
at 16
i think they have like a hundred to go
but uh maybe they'll get there
yeah well maybe they will and it is
special i mean
there's no denying that i mean it's it's
it's awesome it's right up there in that
conversation so i understand you
you know maybe wanting to pick that
first over mahomes and hell
all right well i mean it's his birthday
and i'm a believer
you know that i'm going aaron rodgers
and devonte adams that's just
to me that's a special connection you
know
devonte adams i know i'm a little lower
on how i look at him as a receiver
overall yeah i don't think he's one of
the three or four best receivers top
five
receivers in football i didn't have him
in my top ten as you know i was wrong
he should be in my top ten i don't think
he's top five but
the way he fits with rodgers and that
offense is special
you know he's a really good route runner
and he's got brains to go along with it
but within the the screen game the short
passes and doing all that
it's all the double moves they have off
of it to where him and rogers are on the
same page
so much that are also special that way
let alone adams is one of those guys
it's not a burner
he's not going to catch a slant and go
for a 70-yard touchdown or just
you know run by somebody with his feet
on fire and get an 80-yard bomb
but when he is covered he catches 50 50
balls he catches back shoulder balls
uh i'm gonna take that as my second pick
even though the arizona cardinals have
fallen on rough times since the hail
murray
that connection in and of itself yeah is
sufficient
to put deandre hopkins and kyler murray
onto this list that's my next big
one you know from the get-go it was an
immediate connection without the benefit
of an offseason program
first year together just just wait and
see how they're going to be
next year so kyla murray and deandre
hopkins one of the most exciting
combinations
in the nfl especially because of the
hail murray from just a couple of weeks
ago
yeah that's a damn good one that that
i mean i think we've hit the top four
for sure
like to me i don't i don't think that
was i don't i couldn't argue that
with these four now these next two i'm
interested to see where you're gonna go
i'm gonna talk just full
transparency because i don't know
exactly where you don't know what you're
going to do well i got it i know how it
goes well between
on this one to me it's between josh
allen and stefan diggs
and then it's tana hill and aj brown i
mean when tana hill and aj brown throw
the ball it's touchdowns almost every
time
diggs and allen is special too i'm going
to go with
i'm going to go with tannehill and aj
brown right now as much as i love my boy
i know wow it's just the amount of big
plays they make and i guess the
the way aj brown is playing right now
and what is it like
eight touchdown catches in the last
eight games or something like that
just the fact that he's so hot and on
fire right now i'm just gonna give them
the edge a little bit over
allen and diggs i mean it's so efficient
and it's always for big plays and a
touchdown i feel like with tana hill and
aj brown and i think that's pretty damn
special
and aj brown and dk metcalf from the
same mississippi team
how in the hell did rule college
football
with those guys on the same damn team
dawson knox the tight end for the the
the bills was on that team
i mean it's amazing i used to rail on
that team when during the draft process
that year i couldn't get over it
i'm gonna go with one that that uh i'm
not surprised you didn't go this way
because uh it involves your number 11
quarterback currently
but how can we overlook matt ryan and
julio jones i know
it's not even a thought not even a
consideration no you were going to go
josh allen and stephon diggs no i mean
they've done
too much over the years we cannot
overlook the fact and
they just even though julio jones has
been injured i don't even think he
played last week thank you
just pick josh allen and digs then
because over the years doesn't matter
we're talking about
here right guys listen listen i blew you
away with the first two picks
i can i can throw a bone to your number
11
i don't even know i think calvin ridley
is his number one target this year i
don't even know
you really blew it with that one i don't
i don't care i i don't care i just
wanted to stick it to you a little bit
because you left matt ryan off your top
10 list so matt ryan and julio jones
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports